tato is back and we are headed to China
I am tomorrow Zayn and I'm joined by
Dave do our resident strategy game nerd
yeah alright yeah you played tought war
three kingdoms recently and you came
back very very excited I dabble in
strategy games but your excitement has
kind of rubbed off on me and now I want
to know about it what is it about this
game that's kind of tickled you it's
just got so much there's so many layers
it's every minute I played it and I
played it for five hours
it was something new and fascinating
that had never happened in a total war
game happened to me the three kingdoms
the romance of the three kingdoms
version which is probably the only
version that I'm gonna be playing where
it's very character-driven your generals
can take on hundreds of men on the
battlefield
that's just constantly amazing to see
issuing challenges when you've got like
Guan Yu with the original Lord of war
god of war did I say running across the
battlefield to start Spira at South's ow
it's it's insane to watch there's the
levels of diplomacy the levels of
espionage managing your houses the
relationships that Forge just with you
out you even noticing it's it was tricky
to kind of appreciate and keep on top of
it first because I was used to kind of I
don't know say a simple eternal war
experience but a total war experience
without a lot of these things in and
with all these new layers I was like oh
my god actually I actually am ruling a
kingdom now yeah so like the source
material itself is full of very
recognizable and strong characters how
is that represented in the actual game I
assume I assume it is representing the
game yeah so names that like that the
obvious parallel that is going to be
drawn if dynasty warriors that's the
most popular game that's used the
romance of the three kingdoms as its
backdrop but that's where the similarity
ends it'd be like saying that company
heroes 2 is like Call of Duty World War
2 right they both use ability but
they've got completely different but if
you played any of those games we're
familiar with any of the any of the
Romance of the Three Kingdoms
then all the names you recognizable the
actions with that start the game
instantly recognizable like Liu Bei Guan
Yu Jiang Fei their their bond under the
blossom tree is how that campaign starts
dong zhuo being a tyrant is exactly
portrayed we them with lubu being like a
powerhouse taking down dong Zhuo the
Yellow Turban rebellion it's it's
fascinating to see it all like come to
life and then those the characters that
have there in the game they're written
as they were in the romance novels so
Liu Bei is like an honorable man and
dong Zhuo is a piece and like that from
Waikato like there's there's a lot of
stock put into in this game especially
kind of like your relationships with
other characters and the fact that
they've got all this kind of minutia as
well kind of feeds into the
micromanagement element of a strategy
game like total war like you know you
spend ages trying to keep people happy
and and seeing how that plays out like
did you have any instances of you kind
of interacting over another character
and benefiting you in some way yeah
there was there was a moment I forget
the the the leaders name but it was
basically shared border with me and you
know early game to a war be friendly
with your neighbors trade some food sign
like military access pact great and then
one turn ended and it was like are you
the old man you were mates with he's
dead Sorry mate
he's popped his clogs natural causes and
all that he hasn't popped out sprog he's
left you all his land and immediately I
was like oh my god great I've just got
like three more towns and then I was
like oh my god I've got three more times
I have to manage and then you see the
people that like his court are now
you're caught hmm and some of those
members don't like you so then you have
to work to make them like you by giving
them more status in your kingdom and
then giving them more status upsets the
people that have been with you longer
but I needed to keep them happy because
it's my new town and I my all boys are
pissed off so you give him a present
it's like it's juggling all these
emotions that these virtual people have
it's it was it was bizarre but like tiny
little things were making one guy happy
and piss another dude off this sounds
mad stressful and you know inevitably
ends up in swords clashing so yeah what
always like has the gameplay itself
change because from an outside
perspective for people with little to
you know no investment in the franchise
they probably just see the or you know
these large armies is clashing but on a
on a deeper level you can probably tell
it's changed quite a bit as well right
like what's different about the combat
now the biggest change is the generals
that you take in your your warlords you
have like champions and leaders and
Vanguard's that there are real
powerhouses and can engage in that
intense duels with enemy warlords which
is great because it eliminates a
powerful character and also is like
hugely it destroys enemy morale but then
you also have strategists you can do
like passive buffs have their own suite
of abilities that match their their
class if you will and these are people
that you want to keep happy on on like
the wider world map and again they also
have their own relationship so if better
start the game where I played as Liu Bei
and it's Lubert Liu Bei Guan Yu and
Zhang Fei so their relationship is only
just starting at the start of this this
coalition at the end of the Yellow
Turban rebellion so they're not that
friendly yet and you can you can hear
jibes to each other while they're
fighting you fight like your wife
I forged my wife that's a compliment and
then the more they fight the more they
work together the more they operate
together the closer that bond becomes
which grants bonuses to them fighting
together so all the stuff that's
happening in the in the outer world of
the campaign map that seemed quite
minutia can actually make big impacts
when you take these characters into
power because this game is it's so
character driven in a way that it's
weird to see in a strategy game
it's fascinating man as soon as you
start playing it you start toying with
these characters and like not only
manipulating them just as a leader but
also outside of your control I had one
guy that which played into the Espionage
part I had a guy who joins me when his
faction dissolved so I knew he had a
good relationship with sow sow but then
I paid him or influenced him to go spy
on sow sow which started feeding me
information because sows I liked him he
introduced him as like a chief adviser
feeding me mad information on the table
it was crazy
see that that I'm into sub diffusion
espionage that's how he's the master
manipulator that's why that's what I'll
be going for then it sounds like it's
quite sweeping in the kind of like
improvements and and changes and that
kind of stuff and I think more so than
others like this the kind of Romancing
of three kingdoms angle of it is really
really appealing to me so as a novice
player how easy do you reckon it's going
to be to get into did you get a feel for
kind of like the skill level you need to
go into this game I with the number of
starting factions I think you're gonna
be fine it's gonna appeal to super super
broad skill level whether you want to
focus on the campaign matte weight
whether you want to focus on actual
combat that's just gonna you know that's
just your play style but all the stuff
they've added was interesting to me as a
longtime to a war fan but if someone's
just jumping in to the franchise now
it's it's I think people are gonna pick
up super easy it's another level of
satisfaction and excitement seeing these
larger-than-life character
jump into combat with each other some
people were concerned that would take
something away from the historical stuff
but the thing is you can play the entire
game without the romance stuff without
the large and life characters and gwon
you taking on a hundred years you can
play it like a historical game but I
think that's where this games
strength really is it's because all
these characters and personalities add
so much and such way more than I even
thought it's I think that's like the
best way to play haven't you told me on
keeping an eye on it and checking it out
when it's available hundreds of mad
dudes say that the stock just got
charged in and sounds good to me
I love a bit of loot boo when is the
game out 7th March that's when people
can start taking command of their armies
there's still plenty of time until then
during which I'm sure you'll get a
chance to play more of it and see more
of it or you will specifically yeah yeah
keep an eye on gamespot to see more from
their game we should have a full 20
minute gameplay session on the gameplay
channel and on the site at the minute
and that's got a nice mixture of
interesting campaign map stuff and fight
against south-south I definitely should
have lost but I was really choosing the
motive well I imagine that people who
see that are gonna have more questions
so if you want those answers find a 1/2
a irregular Dave ask him if you want
questions about anime answered you can
find me on twitter at tow hitch metal
gear maybe there's no there's no total
anime yet so that would tell that would
be interesting wouldn't it when that
happens that's the day I let you go to
orbit